ضربه الايراني استهدفت مقر احزاب كرديه
ايرانيه معارضه مستقره في اقليم كردستان
العراق
طائره مسيره وخمسه صواريخ على الاقل يقف
خلفها الحرس الثوري الايراني اصابه اهداف
مختلفه في اقليم اربيل وفي محافظه
السليمانيه تقول ايران
الارهابيه ويتعلق الامر بقوه الكرديه
ايرانيه توجد مقرها في العراق
كانوا يحرسون المباني والممتلكات بداخلها
المناطق المصادفه مواقع كانت توجد فيها
عائله عسكريه
رئيس حكومه اقليم كردستان العراق مسرور
بارزاني اذان القصف الايراني معتبرا اياه
انتهاك للسياده في مقاله وزاره الخارجيه
العراقيه انها تدين بشده استهداف
المواطنين العراقيين
هذا النهج الاحادي العدائي
وسبقت مواقفنا لتؤشر على خطر هذا التجاوز
السافر على سياده العراق وامن مواطنيه وما
يعكسه من تهديد مستمر سيتسبب بارباك
المنطقه ويرفع مستوى التوتر
في العمق العراقي
حضرت وسائل اعلام ايرانيه من ان الضربات
ليست الا موجه الاولى من عمليات عده
تستهدف الاكراد في شمال العراق
وسبق لايران الجنه ضد احزاب كرديه في
العراق قبل شهرين ما يهدد بجفاء دبلوماسي
بين طهران وبغداد